welcome to my mind palace
it's 4 am and i'm about to bust into a
lamp 3 2 1 action
welcome to my mind palace
can i execute on this project can i walk
away with this with all the footage
required to make a half decent piece
with full control over it we keep saying
this word sam's spooky video and i think
it's because it's the colloquial term
for a video that no one really has any
idea why it's being made or what it's
about or what the actual final title's
going to be
please no no
it's a little different than the videos
i've made and i guess anyone in the
studio has made because some of the
stuff adrian was working on was kind of
similar in vain but even still this was
definitely a departure it was a
departure for a very specific reason
it's not a video that was necessarily
created in a fit of inspiration but more
of as a test that i kind of devised for
myself
we have three nights to shoot this video
here over the course of those three
nights we have lots of things people we
have locations we have monsters we have
to figure out what's the best order to
shoot everything in it's just not hero
but it's still like close enough to
it'll be okay okay
that that gives me a lot more confidence
basically we have a schedule here um i
have a shot list here and then we have
this with my
chicken scratches basically the sort aka
storyboards for reminders of how we're
shooting each scene there's uh
one two three
four
five
like true encounters with the creature
that does look like a close-up of the
monster here at the end but uh we can
easily switch that okay um so we can
avoid that
yeah we have the couch we're gonna put
it on the other side
so our moonlight can actually hit it
okay the camera pushes in see it happens
the living room is a location to come
back to frequently
so there's a little thing of like all
right well
how big is our lighting setup for this
do we want to just shoot out more living
room stuff right away
or do we want to like
stick to chronological
now i think jake was a little ambitious
here with fitting a second
ghost bit being here
but
um
i mean i think it's probably it's
probably worth just attempting to get it
all done so to fully understand why we
went through with making this video we
have to go back a few years
let's go
okay well we've always wanted to make
movies the whole reason we started this
youtube channel is because we were into
movies we're into cinema we wanted to
make movies but youtube was the more
accessible route for us where we could
make stuff get released no barriers and
that was great but the thing is is that
in order to kind of find success in
doing that we had to shift the genre a
little bit you know youtube isn't
necessarily the best place for serious
drama or things like that uh it's a
little better for you know action and
comedy and things that are quick
entertaining loud spectacle driven bite
size it's definitely elements that you
can bring into that film world and give
you that great experience of working
with actors but it's not necessarily the
same thing so in order to kind of
achieve those goals you know we kind of
did sync we did rush we filmed lifeline
so you so where do you always start this
is the thing i see dan carlin's issue
because when you talk talk about a story
it's like where where is the beginning
of this story you know same spooky video
where's the beginning how to understand
it nick ask me why did you make this
video why did you make spooky
well
uh night one here in idaho california
and we are filming sam's spooky house
aka turn off we're doing some crazy
creature stuff some crazy kind of love
triangle drama and we have some crazy
intense
katherine
we have some crazy intense creature
makeup that catherine will be wearing
you know got some extra limbs yeah some
extra limbs i don't have enough you
actually might remember captain from our
previous horror short rot she was the uh
screaming lady on the ground
so we brought her back and we're gonna
put her in some insane moth like
prosthetic costumes so she's gonna be
getting real creepy so
she's already getting it down i really
don't like the zombie hands at all
come on no they're so nice
[Music]
i'm really excited because i feel like
it will be so cool it's like black eyes
and i won't be able to see anything
all right step outside
we got we have the blind
here we go
first creature shot of the whole
short
uh cool and just uh turn your head
slightly to your left
take her hair and have it parked down in
front of her face a little more so yeah
there we go there we go
there we go cool all right let's do it
the reason i made spooky was because
after my experience filming rush the
battlefield series after my experience
filming lifeline i actually came away
from those experiences really
kind of with a loss of confidence
actually more than anything else we went
into it with really high hopes but each
project kind of came out on the other
side and i was sitting there going like
oh my god oh this stuff messed up or
something went wrong or this thing sucks
they're like oh like what's going on and
lifeline that whole process like it was
doubling down because way more actors
huge casts tons of scripts lots of
dialogue and just like you know frankly
dialogue is a genre that we don't do a
lot here kind of came away from those
projects going on what the frick
something went wrong somewhere to make
this lackluster project and i need to
figure out what it is it's like was this
me was it the actors was it the script
was it like some other weird factor that
was happening i couldn't figure it out i
need to devise some sort of standardized
test that i can take where my strengths
or weaknesses lie what went wrong what
was is it me is it like am i the kink in
the chain well we got to figure this out
what better place to start than with the
horror genre if you're talking about
standardized tests the horror genre is
standard there's a format there's a
formula yes it's evolving yes it's
changing but i would say more than any
other genre it's a little more cut and
dry all right let's make a short film 10
pages long actors drama dialogue some
effects some spectacle and let's see how
it goes if i if i don't get like at
least like a 7 out of 10 on this
standardized test
maybe
maybe i should stick to just making like
two minute mario fight scenes the rest
of my life because
maybe that's all i'm good at
[Music]
yeah i guess so okay
one of our coolest probably artists set
pieces custom made by caitlin husband
that's right yeah you guys like pizza
here's a comparison how about that pizza
um
so this is
blood pools so instead of having to pour
liquid blood all over a rented place and
growing it forever and carpet
you can just put it down
without making a mess and then another
one looks like blood
i'm about to crash through this
uh lamp
so we'll see how it goes i hope i don't
break this door that's what i'm hoping i
don't do
the time
before it's late 4am
it's 4 am and i'm about to bust into a
lounge
i'm set
camera's rolling 3 2 1 action
you all right you all right yeah is that
any good though
dude i'm so glad you had the dimmer on
there i know i turned it off kind of
brutal because like it's it's so fast
cut
brutal we're done that's a wrap
that is a wrap on the three night shoot
project
turn off subscribe
to quarter crew and corridor youtube
channel to see it when it comes out
looking at the project now that it's
almost done but you know honestly i
don't want to rate it i feel like i feel
like i passed i feel like i passed
the final question that i asked myself
before i went into filming this was can
i execute on this project can i walk
away with this with all the footage
required to make a decent like even a
half decent piece with full control over
it i
think i did so
i feel a little bit better now once
again i still have strengths and i still
have weaknesses and i think this piece
shows that off so if you're one of the
select few that hasn't seen the video go
check it out and if you have seen the
video well
i guess uh i would have a small request
uh this video was done without any
sponsors it was all out of pocket
definitely a passion project so if you
enjoyed it consider hopping on our merch
store getting a cool hat or shirt
something to support the channel or go
over to patreon where you can support us
monthly hopefully we can get more videos
like this out there for you to watch so
thanks for watching guys